ambos acusados se señalaron mutuamente a
lo largo del proceso finalmente un
tribunal de parís declaró a yasin muse
culpable del asesinato de vida y no en
marzo de 2018 el juez dictó una
sentencia de 22 años él sin libertad
condicional por el asesinato impulsado
por motivos antisemitas mientras que el
otro acusado jared carril backus
absuelto por el homicidio cumplirá 15
años por robo también con motivos
antisemitas para la familia de nohl es
una oportunidad para sanar heridas y
seguir adelante
los meses y el ritmo estoy realmente
satisfecho con este veredicto que me
tranquiliza ahora tenemos la certeza de
que nuestras familias nuestra sociedad
estarán a salvo de estas personas
durante el mayor tiempo posible esa era
una de las mayores prioridades para
nosotros y 7-5
mire de 85 años fue encontrada muerta en
su casa hace tres años luego de haber
sido apuñalada 11 veces y parcialmente
quemada de niña había escapado de las
redadas de judíos durante la segunda
guerra mundial el asesinato de una
persona enferma de parkinson incapaz de
defenderse conmocionó a francia los
investigadores no tardaron en sospechar
de un contexto antisemita en su muerte
el hijo de una de sus vecinas eliazim
juve y su amigo álex cardin backus
fueron detenidos pronto ambos tenían
antecedentes penales y se conocieron en
la cárcel allí habían alimentado
mutuamente sus prejuicios en contra de
los judíos convencidos de una supuesta
riqueza que mire y no le había ocultado
en su apartamento por haber escondido
pruebas el tribunal también condenó a la
madre de muse a tres años de prisión dos
de ellos en suspenso